The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GANG CHEN: OK, on the take-home
exam you did very well.
I think the average was 88.
That's very comfortable.
That means everybody
has learned something.
So you will say that I take a
quick look at Jonathan, read
very carefully, and
overall very pleased.
I was impressed that
there was a lot of math,
and everybody is writing
down a lot of formulas.
OK, so the last is the best,
and after today, you can go out,
celebrate hopefully.
And we have a new president.
You heard it?
OK.
So what I was
planning to talk about
is on the molecular
dynamics simulation,
and really how they
emphasize in the analysis
of molecular
dynamics simulation.
So molecular dynamics simulation
conceptually is very easy.
What we want is--
actually most of the molecular
dynamics simulation nowadays
is based on classical
molecular dynamics.
And in fact, people
think it's done.
So the chalk, I like
this thick chalk.
And we'll have to
use a different one.
OK, so the classical molecular
dynamics is F=ma And so force
equals MA.
So if I have, for
example, a simulation box,
I have a crystal.
I want to simulate
its properties.
And what I have,
Newton's second law
will tell me the mass
of the ice atom, ma,
so the acceleration
of the ice atom
equals the force
acting on the atom.
So we have the force of all the
other atoms j equals 1 to n.
The n is the number of atoms
simulating in the domain.
And Fij, so that's the force
acting on this specific atom.
And, of course, j
doesn't equal to i.
So that's the concept.
It's very easy.
And in fact, any time, say, when
new students come in and say,
OK, this is the easiest.
You start from here.
Of course, you can think
about your task there as doing
integration of F=ma, and
you make sure that you have
the proper potential, the force.
Remember, the force equals
the gradient of the potential,
so we need a proper potential.
And at least
conceptually, we have
discussed in this course
different potentials,
[INAUDIBLE] potential, ionic
potentials, covalent potential.
So all those potential
interactions.
And the reality is, for
each different material
when you do classical
molecular dynamics simulation,
the different material--
people have spent a lot of time
to put the proper
potential so that they
can reproduce some of the
materials basic properties
like melting point.
When you heat it up, it melts.
Or the mechanical properties.
And because those
are not potential
from first principle--
when I say first principle,
it's of quantum mechanics.
Those are the
classical potential,
and typically you
start with some concept
and you put in the
feeding parameters,
adjust the parameter
to say these
are the best set of parameters
for those materials.
But we're not getting
into discussing how
to construct those potentials.
Typically, if you are able to
construct the potential that's
more general, many
people used, you
have already achieved a
good success in this field.
It's not easy to construct
these potentials.
And once you have the
potential of this second order
derivative, you
have the potential,
you do a integration.
And you want to
find the position
of the atoms, molecules,
as a function of time
in your simulation domain.
So we can do the integration.
So, for example, the second
order derivative we know--
let's drop the vector location.
So the second order
derivative, drop
the vector of i and
dt squared equals
ri and the t plus the other t--
I use the central difference
method, for example--
and plus the rt it minus the
other t, match to our it.
This is a time integration over
that 2 to the other t squared.
So if you go to check
the accuracy of this,
this is actually of the
order of the other t.
This is the fourth
order, so fourth power.
So you actually have a
relatively high accuracy
when you use the central
difference method.
And then if I write this,
you choose a time step--
so this is an explicit method.
You choose a time step.
You advance it in time to
find the position of the atoms
at the next time.
So you use the--
so the next time
is t plus delta t.
You use the information previous
time step, the current time
step, and previous time step.
So I can integrate--
I say I can march in
time t plus delta t.
And what I have here is then--
this one is, if you look
at the Newton second law,
is really just
the f divide by m.
So what I have here is a 2 ri
1 minus ri t minus delta t.
And there I have the derivative
of the acceleration, which
is 2 delta t squared
times the force acting
on this atom in that specific
direction divided by mass.
That's my acceleration.
And now, if I do this,
what I am accurate
is to delta t fourth power.
That's the terms that I dropped.
So this is-- to
the fourth power is
called high numerical accuracy.
And what's important
is your time step.
You say, OK, I'm going to
accelerate my integration,
I choose a very large time step.
But remember, your
time step has to be
smaller than the physical
process that goes on.
If I have atoms oscillate
10 to the 14th hertz,
that means 10 to the
minus 14 second or period.
Then my delta t has
to be, if I want
to capture one period
of the atom oscillation,
you say that the
sine function, I
have to at least how accurate.
I say, OK, maybe I'll take 1/10.
That's not very fine
points for a sine function.
So you can say,
then, usually you
get to femtosecond,
very small time steps.
And because of that,
your integration time,
you want to simulate the
event that last a nanosecond.
And nanosecond, 10 to minus 9.
If you start from 10
to minus 15 time step,
you can imagine that's
a lot of marching
and a lot of computation.
And each time step, you have to
re-calculate the force because
of the timing position
change and that will
change the force interactions.
So this is a time.
And with this, you can
also calculate velocity.
Velocity for the time, t,
is just a graded derivative.
So we have the derivative
of for the i, the t.
Then I have ri t plus
the delta t which
I calculate in this
time And I have ri
t and divide it by delta t.
And the disadvantage
of this compared
to a central difference,
this accuracy is lower.
So only t square.
But it's lucky that this
doesn't quite effect--
this does not, in fact, does
not affect my calculation of ri.
Because my ri calculation is
independent of the velocity.
So my velocity is
not that accurate,
my position is
much more accurate.
Depends on the
time step you take.
So that's easy, right?
So in principle,
you can write a code
and do this calculation quickly.
And the key question is,
how do you do your analysis?
How you understand
your analysis?
Doing a numerical
simulation many times,
people like to say I'm doing
a numerical experiment I
don't like that terminology.
But if you are doing
computation like this,
say you're doing
numerical experiments,
the question is how you
analyze your experiment?
So what are we going to
discuss focus is really
the statistical foundation
for numerical analysis.
One more comment,
before we go there,
is that when you do
molecular dynamics simulation
already set, your time
step has to be very short.
Let's say if you
do solid, you have
to go to femtosecond or
even sub-femtosecond.
It depends on the oscillation
frequency of the atoms.
And the other is the number
of atoms you can simulate.
And if I think I want to
simulate one micron cube.
and if you say the typical,
let's say, silicon crystal.
A silicon crystal
lattice constant
is about five Armstrong.
So in a five Armstrong
cube, there are eight atoms.
And a one nanometer cube,
that's, say, eight times
eight is 64.
And the one micron is a
tenth to the ninth power
because three order of magnitude
higher in each direction.
And that's s 10
to nine times 64.
That's a number of items
you got in one micron cube.
And with that many
times steps, and that
needs very high powerful
computer to even
simulate one micron.
So that's very hard.
And typically, people do
periodic boundary condition.
So they try to similu--
use a much smaller
simulation box.
And you have molecules
or atoms in the box.
And the next moment,
this atom can move out
of the simulation box.
And the way that cleverly
taken into this moving out
is in the opposite direction,
obviously boundaries.
So here it goes out of
boundary and it comes in.
This atom comes in
at the position,
at the velocity, the
corresponding position
on the opposite boundary, and
the velocity that it exit.
So this is the trick that
people use periodic boundary
condition.
And with that, you hope
to recapture the effects
of infinite simulation.
Anytime you use a purely
boundary condition,
you actually say in the specific
direction where it's periodic,
it's infinite.
And there are also
artifacts that's
caused by this periodic
boundary condition
as you would see much
easier once we got
into the statistical aspects.
And let's look into the
statistical foundation.
And first, in chapter four,
when we do the statistics,
we introduce the concept
of ensemble average.
In the old days,
you do not actually
trace the trajectory, the
time trajectory, of atoms.
Remember, molecular
dynamics is looking--
the way we describe, it is
looking to the time trajectory
of the atoms.
And when we discuss
the statistics,
we said that's too complicated.
That we're actually going to
do ensemble average rather than
time average.
And then we introduce the
concept of ergodicity,
our system for ergodic system.
The ensemble average
equals the time average.
Of course, the
time average, if I
have a quantity, this quantity
is the quantity in phase space,
for example, is position and
momentum of many particles.
I'm just using r
represent maybe millions
or billions of atoms position
and corresponding momentum.
And when I do the time
average of this quantity,
I say this is--
I observe this quantity over a
certain period of time starting
any time t plus delta t.
So this is the origin.
If I do my average correctly
and this origin doesn't matter.
So here I have, this is a,
that phase space variable,
for example, I can write the
potential energy or kinetic
energy or total energy
in terms of the energy
of every particle.
This is the total
energy I averaged
over a certain amount of time.
So here, this r, remember,
is a function of time.
Momentum is a function of time.
And I integrate, and
that's a definition.
If I look long enough, I get
my average quantity energy
or momentum or pressure.
They share stress, all of
the quantities of the system.
So this is the time averaging.
And then I do the ensemble
average of this quantity,
I use a bracket.
And remember,
ensemble average is,
I look at the
probability function.
We see microcanonical ensemble.
Each of the system in the
ensemble is equal probability.
Canonical ensemble is the
Boltzmann distribution
or we also introduce where the
gaps in sample there where.
There is not only constant
temperature, but also
mass flow, flux, with ambient.
So at the end, when I do
that the ensemble average,
I average over the probability.
So the ensemble average is
I will have this phase space
variable r and p.
And then I integrate over
the phase space variables.
And then I have my probability
distribution four m particle
in the system and r and p, and
I will-- this is my integration.
When I do double
i, really mean many
because the r and p is
all the particles momentum
and position.
So ergodic system
means my time average
equals ensemble average.
And in the past, we had
really follow this trajectory.
We were-- when I solved
Boltzmann equation,
I simplify this n particle
distribution function into one
particle distribution function.
And I do the average
velocity or heat flux
as we have been doing.
And when you do
molecular dynamics
you are simulating
time trajectory.
So you're really
interested in how
I'm going to do the time average
to get the quantities that I'm
interested in.
For example, if
I want to compute
the thermal conductivity,
viscosity of the system,
I will look at the atomic
positions as a function of time
and how I can extract
this information that I'm
interested in.
So those are the questions.
And let's look at--
I'm interested in the property,
thermal conductivity, electric
conductivity.
And so, in general,
those are the response
if I-- so let's discuss
the response function.
And let me look
into a system that
is initially at equilibrium.
So system-- equilibrium system.
And a system Hamiltonian,
the Hamiltonian typically
you can understand
the Hamiltonian
as the kinetic energy
plus the potential energy.
So the system of Hamiltonian
is H0, equilibrium.
Let's say, the volume
is V. And then, I'm
going to give a
disturbance to the system.
I push the system.
I push it every atom.
Or I somehow inject some heat.
So right now, my disturbance
I'm going to say,
I'm going to give a small
disturbance and uniform
through this space.
And this doesn't really matter.
You can extend to
a long uniform.
But because I have a
perturbation due to a force.
So I use a force to perturb it.
And because I'm applying
force, the system Hamiltonian,
the energy of the
system will change,
and that change is H
prime, small change.
So I will say, this is the
perturbation to the Hamiltonian
of the system.
And I can write
this perturbation
because this is
the force applied.
So this will be related to the
position and kinetic energy
of each atom in the system.
So this relation,
Hamiltonian, is
expressed in this perturbation.
And this is the force applied.
And I do a normalization
to the volume.
So I have my volume there.
And I put a negative
sign, and that
doesn't matter because that
could be absorbed into any.
So this is my
perturbed Hamiltonian.
And now, so this
is really what is
perturbing due to this force to
individual atoms or molecules.
And sometime later, I want
to look at the response.
I want to look at how
the heat flux change,
how the shared stress change.
And the shared stress, again, is
reflected by another quantity.
Let's say this is a B, again,
is the individual face space
variable.
And this one, this
is the response.
This is the disturbance.
So in the case where
the system is linear,
my force is not very large.
Then this response I know will
be proportional to the force.
So this is a linear
disturbance-- linear response
regime.
And so what I have
is, this is my force.
I apply at certain time t prime.
And this force could be
continuously varying,
time-varying.
And then from the start of
time to the current time--
because this r and the t
of the atoms in the system
could be a function of time.
It's changing, because
apply the external force.
And this is just related to
a response function here.
And that's a function
that I'm interested.
So B, A. And this is a t
prime, this I'm looking at a t,
time t, so t minus t prime.
So this is at--
the instant that is active.
And after some time,
what's my system response?
What's this response-- this
quantity is responding?
It's just the only
assumption I have here
is a linear small disturbance.
So that this response is
proportional to the first power
of my force.
So here, this
would be A, say phi
is after effect of function.
This is a general describe
what happens after apply
a disturbance to the system.
So it should be a real
observable-- real quantity.
And this is, in fact, is also
sometimes you probably some
of you you heard the causality.
F is the cause, and later
on it has a response.
So you should not-- those
results are general.
You cannot violate, and those
are the causality requirement.
So what we have written
is in real time.
And of course, you can always
express those properties
in the frequency domain.
You can do the Fourier
transform of force.
And if you do your Fourier
transform, and we have here--
I should do the
ensemble average.
I want to look at the
Fourier transform.
And then I can use the
Fourier space response.
And I'm not going to derive it.
But this can be proven.
And at B, A--
so this is the
disturbance starts with A.
And this disturbed
quantity due to that force.
And the response is a specific
response, for example,
like I said, viscosity.
So here is a frequency.
And the force is also Fourier
transform and exponential i
omega t and d omega.
So you can say that this
susceptibility that we usually
call dynamic susceptibility
of the system
must be related to the
after effect function here.
In fact, this susceptibility--
so here we have
dynamic susceptibility
of the system xBA omega is
actually the Fourier transform
of a-- so it's a 0 to infinite,
phi BA tau exponential minus
i omega tau d tau.
So if I know this, I know
the after-effect function.
Or if I know
after-effect function,
I know the susceptibility.
And in fact, there is a
really interesting relation
between this one could be
real part and imaginary part.
Because I'm here I have--
in the Fourier transform
I have i there.
So I have a real part.
I have an imaginary part.
I can write, OK, I
have a real part.
Plus i imaginary part.
And both are
frequency dependent.
You can say, because
this is really
just a cosine or sine part
of the Fourier transform,
if I do a cosine.
So if know real part of
this frequency dependence,
I can go inverse cosine
transform and get this function
here.
From this function, I
can do a sine transform.
I can get the imaginary part.
So which means the real and
imaginary part are always
related.
And this relation is the
Kramers-Kronig relation.
It's very general.
If you do thermal
radiation you probably
heard of, for example,
the dielectric constant
or optical constant.
You can calculate if
you measure real part,
you can calculate
imaginary part.
If you measure imaginary part,
you can calculate real part.
That's example of the
Kramers-Kronig relation.
And so, the real
part, for example,
can be calculated
from imaginary part.
And minus infinite to plus
infinite, imaginary part,
omega prime.
And the omega prime minus
omega d omega prime.
So you can say, the
problem of this integration
is when omega
prime equals omega.
Because I'm
integrating from minus
infinite to plus infinite.
This blow up.
So this has to be--
this is in the front.
You put a [INAUDIBLE]
principle value.
So actually, there's a
negative sign for this part.
And that's just
to say, when the--
going from left approaching to
omega or from right approaching
to omega is separated
with the limit
either the singularity point.
And similarly, there
is a relation--
you switch-- there's
no more sign.
It's a positive sign.
You switch this with this,
you get another relation.
So either way, if you know the
real and know imaginary part,
but you need to say, if you
look at this function here,
you need to know
the whole function
as a function of frequency.
If you just have-- if you
do an optical measurement
and you know only
a section of that,
you may not be accurate enough
to do this inverse using
the Kramers-Kronig relation.
And this is a causality of what
sometimes the people say this
is a causality requirement.
You can see that we don't
have assumptions there.
And what's also
interesting, if you
say this is a response on
different face-based variable.
But if B is the same as A,
and the A is related to--
because the A is here--
is a disturbance
to the Hamiltonian,
the energy of the system.
So in fact, when
B equals A, there
is a useful relation
that's a B equals A.
And what we have is
the energy dissipated
in the system due to this
external disturbance.
And the E equals is related
to the imaginary part
of the dynamic susceptibility.
So omega over 2 V, x AA.
So B equals A now,
the imaginary part.
And omega F omega squared.
So this is just a result out
of, again, the causality.
And it's general.
And here, we're discussing
the response function.
And next, let's move on.
So I have now the system has
a small perturbation, H prime.
And initially, it was at
equilibrium situation.
We have F, say the H0.
And now, after
this perturbation,
the distribution
function will change.
Because the Hamiltonian of the
system change and distribution
function will changes.
So now, you see the approach I
mentioned before, one of those
approaches going towards
my equation, the Fn,
the n particle
distribution function
is reduced to one particle
distribution function.
And that's the Boltzmann
equation approach.
And what we go in, in this
approach is a linearize,
is actually taking the n
particle distribution function.
So the linear
response theory start
from the Liouville equation.
And but let's say,
linearize Liouville equation
but still keep the n
particle distribution.
So if we go back to the
Liouville equation--
and this is the
Liouville equation
rated in operator form.
So the Liouville
equation is an equation
for the n particle distribution
function as a function of time.
And we could write
this in operator.
So the H, the Hamiltonian
of the system,
and the Fn, this bracket is
called the Poisson bracket.
I'll explain what it mean.
And then say there's
also another notation.
And this is using i gamma
operator and the Fn.
Here, the point is I'm writing
a Liouville equation with--
and this is the original
Liouville equation with the n
particle distribution function.
And location-wise, what we have
on the right-hand side, first
so that's the curly bracket
is a Poisson bracket.
And that's just a location
if you have a and b.
And what it means is because
I have i particulars.
So i equals 1 to--
in fact, say this are the total
number of degrees of freedom.
If I have capital N particle,
and each N particle,
each particle has a three
degree, that's a 3N.
If it's a six degree, it's a 6N.
So this is a--
and then I have dA and dri,
dB dpi, minus dA dpi dB dri.
And with this notation,
you put it in back
into the right-hand
side, that you get back
to the original
Liouville equation
that we have
written down before.
And this one, gamma
here, is the operator.
So gamma is the definition,
is the operator, is minus i,
and the H, and whatever behind
this function is put in here.
This is the operator notation.
And the use of-- this is
the Liouville operator.
The use of this
Liouville operator
is now with this
written as this form,
you can just think of this as an
ordinary differential equation.
And you have to go in back
into all this detailed math.
But think this is the ordinary
differential equation.
You solve it as the
exponential function.
That's the use of
this Liouville.
And of course, the gamma you
keep it as an operator form.
And now, so what do we have?
The system Hamiltonian
is the H0 plus H prime.
I have a perturbation
to the system energy.
And then, correspondingly, the
n particle distribution function
is f0n.
That's corresponding
to equilibrium.
And then, a small
perturbation f1, and that due
to the perturbation H prime.
And f0n is related to--
because it's at equilibrium,
so you can write it as H
kBt, that's the Boltzmann
distribution there
at for system at--
so the way that
I'm written here,
f0 here is a canonical
distribution, canonical system.
And so, once I have those, I
put in here into this equation,
I use the operator.
And I neglected-- the term I
neglected is H prime times f1.
Because that's a H prime is a
lower order, small disturbance.
f1 is small disturbance.
So I drop that cross term.
That's a higher order.
And with that, I can solve for
f1 in the operator notation.
So I will have f1n and trp
That's the face space variable,
or the is the V
kBt, that comes--
the V kBt come from f0n.
And minus infinite to t.
And exponential minus i,
t minus t prime gamma.
If you look at this
exponential that come from--
I treated that gamma
just like a constant.
I do integration.
That's the operator math there.
And gamma 0, this gamma 0 is
corresponding to when H is H0.
And then I have the
time derivative of this.
Because H prime has A. So
I have time derivative.
In the A, I have r is
a function of time.
And p is a function of time.
That's why I can do
the time derivative.
And I have f t prime.
And this is a--
or t prime.
And then I have f0
2n, and the dt prime.
So this is the solution to
the perturbed distribution
function, n particle
distribution function.
Remember, gamma is an operator.
It looks simple, but
it's an operator.
And for this operator,
in fact, if you
want to operate what's
the function behind,
you have to expand this
back into using the Taylor
expansion.
So that you can't just put
this stuff inside the exponent.
And so, what's the
use of this is,
once I have this
former solution,
I can go back to calculate
the ensemble average.
Because my ensemble
average is any quantity
in terms of the momentum and
the location of the system times
distribution function.
Now, distribution
function consists
of for equilibrium part
and the perturbation part.
In most transport, if I
deal with the transport,
I know that the equilibrium
part will drop out.
And this is the deviation part
that gives me the response.
So I do this.
I go to calculate.
And for example, we were writing
this before the response,
or be you can say
this is once you
do the substitute into the n
particle averaging expression.
At the end, what you get
is the dt prime f t prime.
That's the-- and then, here
we have a V kBt, V kBt.
And integration for f0n.
And then we have a Brpt.
And the exponential minus i,
t minus t prime gamma 0 A dot.
And here I have our rt
prime p t prime, and dr, dp.
And here, the bracket.
And the reason I'm
writing into this form
is because inside the bracket
is my after-effect function.
This is the disturbance.
This is the response
I'm interested in,
the quantity of response.
And this one is my
after-effect function
due to that disturbance that
created the A, which is a phase
function in the Hamiltonian.
So this one is my after-effect,
the function BAt minus t prime,
as I defined before.
Here I have a t minus t prime.
And if you use further the
operator notation, this one,
the operator properties,
you can get the following.
So here we're not going to
write all the derivation.
I know this is a
pretty lot of writing.
I want to appreciate,
because I said
before, you have
Boltzmann approach,
you have linear response
theory approach.
And linear response
theory is really developed
after the computational
power, say
in combination with the
computational techniques.
So t minus t prime.
Now, if you look at
this, it could be V kBt.
After you actually
do this operation,
use that as the
operator properties.
And we can say here is f0n.
And A dot, that's a time
derivative rt prime pt prime.
And look at the time
already is important.
B here is rt minus t prime,
because of this operator,
and pt minus t prime.
So now, this is the quantity
in the time before dr, dp.
Here, you can see, this is
this face space average.
Because here is a
distribution function,
equilibrium
distribution function.
And this disturbance is out.
It actually does
not get into my--
A does not get into my B. It's
independent of the disturbance.
This is the when I do
thermal conductivity,
viscosity is a physical
property of the system.
And this is a statistic-- the
ensemble average, because here,
that's what we define.
And this is the quantity
at two different times.
So this is a cross
correlation function.
And with this, you can convert
also back into the time.
Because we say it's
ergodic system.
Here is ensemble average.
Now you can convert back
into the time average.
So we could write
this kBt, that's
the ensemble average
of quantity t
must t prime and the quantity
by the t prime derivative.
And this time origin
is not important.
So you can write t.
And A at this origin you
choose whatever time is 0.
And this one, there are
different ways to write it.
You can write V kBt, and rather
than the derivative of A,
you can write the
derivative of B and time t.
And this all can be proven.
I'm just giving
you the expression.
And what it means here
is all time averaging--
the ensemble averaging.
But when I do
molecular dynamics,
I do the time
averaging because--
so what it means is, I have
this ensemble averaging
is equal to time averaging.
So t prime plus
t, and A t prime.
So the bar in the up is the
time averaging as we introduced.
So now we have--
so you can simulate
an equilibrium system
and to get that the
properties with the response
because the force is taken out.
And with this, of course, you
know the after-effect function.
You can get the
frequency component--
as we have written
down the susceptibility
as a function of frequency.
And in fact, if
you write further--
because the susceptibility
now can be calculated as here,
if I look at this one,
the autocorrelation when
A goes to itself, that's
an autocorrelation.
When go to different quantity,
it's a cross correlation.
So now, the
imaginary part can be
related to the autocorrelation
function when B equals A.
And what you have here,
that from that expression
I can write the imaginary
part of the susceptibility
as a function of frequency
is V omega and 2 kBt,
and minus infinite to plus
infinite, exponential minus i
omega t.
And the A at the t, A at 0 dt.
So from the cross-correlation,
the auto-correlation,
I can calculate imaginary part.
And this is, I
mentioned many times,
this is actually the
fluctuation dissipation theorem.
This is the fluctuation,
auto-correlation.
The imaginary part
is the dissipation.
Because that imagined part
is related to the energy
dissipated in the system.
So this is a fluctuation
dissipation theorem
general form.
And when I do, for example,
near-field radiation
simulation, we use a lot of
this fluctuation dissipation
theorem.
And what I do is the
current fluctuation
is related to the imaginary
part of the dielectric constant.
That's one example of the
fluctuation dissipation
theorem.
And if you do the quantum,
you can generalize
in the quantum limit.
And what you have here,
the imaginary part,
you will have to write this as
a H bar, and the cotangent--
so this is a hyperbolic
cotangent function, H
bar omega 2 kBt
and minus infinite
to plus infinite exponential
minus [INAUDIBLE] t.
And Ap A0.
So that's the quantum foam of
modification to fluctuation
dissipation theorem.
So now, this is the essence
of the linear response.
And what I need next is
to give a few examples.
For example, how I can relate
the electric conductivity
and calculate it based on the--
if I have ions in the system.
So writing down the
corresponding form.
So if I have ions in the system,
and I apply an electric field
to the system.
And so now each ions--
what we say, so they feel
that will give a force.
Force will move the ion.
And force times distance
it gives me the work.
That's the additional
energy that the system
is subject to perturbation.
So we have then look either the
perturbation and Hamiltonian
can be written as i
equals 1 to n particles.
And the displacement, ri,
you can do ri minus r0.
But let's say, then r0 is
the original Hamiltonian.
So is ri.
And then, the force
is the charge.
So I have the i-th atom, has,
I say, the ion zi charge.
And I have then E, which
is a function of time.
This is the perturbation.
And from here, going
back to the definition,
I know my A. Because
I want to express A
in terms of the face variable.
This should equal to, according
to my definition, minus A VE,
which is my disturbance.
And so, my A here then
equals minus V sigma i
equals 1 to n, zi, E, ri.
And I can look at,
for example, current.
What's my response?
Given an electric field,
I want to look at what's
the current in the system.
So my current of the system
is the charge times velocity.
So the current in the system
is a charge times velocity.
So ziE and dri, dt.
i equals 1 to n.
And so, I do in terms of
the per unit volume, again.
And you can see here,
I was a little bit--
I'm trying to reconcile my sign.
I haven't been able
to reconcile my sign.
So I write this as the
gradient, because here
is dr, dt, here is dr, dt.
So with that, I can then now
look at this is essentially--
this is the response
I want to look at.
And that's my B. So
I have A. I have B.
And now, I can write the--
use the expression we have,
the after-effect function.
And in fact, what
we have here is
if I write into the
frequency for J omega
equals the electric
conductivity,
which is usually tensile.
Thermal conductivity is
tensile, electric conductivity
is tensile and six
component, and is
related to the tensile
product to the electric field.
That's the response.
And this is the after-effect.
That's the frequency component.
Here is a real-time component.
And that's a
frequency expression.
And I can use the
real-time real component.
And so, what I have here, then
the electric conductivity--
so the electrical
conductivity, if you use--
what we have here
can be written,
particularly if I do isotropic,
I can write each direction.
But now I do isotropic.
So then I don't have
the other things
are component only diagonal.
And in that case, I can average.
So is the 3 kBt, and
0 infinite Jxt, J0--
Jx0, and plus Jyt, Jy at
time 0, Jzt, Jz at time 0.
Time 0 is the origin you choose.
And then, I have exponential
minus i omega t, dt.
So this is my
frequency component
of the electric conductivity
of the system I simulated.
So in a real
simulation, you solve
F equals ma, if you know
the force interaction
between these atoms.
And then, once you have that,
you write the time derivative.
That's your current flux.
And then, you calculate those
are the time auto-correlation
function.
And then we'll see, why it
started because I say isotopic.
And so, I'm averaging
over three directions.
So this is, in fact,
what we have here
is the Green-Kubo formulation.
This is the Green-Kubo formula.
We can write from
the, say, we can
calculate the time response.
And from there, we can
calculate also the frequency.
It's a simple frequency,
the Fourier transform.
And Green-Kubo, they
didn't write one paper,
they developed this as an
independent of each other.
So this is the case for the
electrical, the expression,
final expression for the
electric conductivity.
And in fact, I say, to
derive a Green-Kubo formula
for thermal conductivity
was not easy.
And the reason for
that is, in this case,
the derivation process that
we were using the system
have an external disturbance f.
And the thermal is an
internal disturbance--
the thermal fluctuation
of the system.
And there are many derivations.
The cleanest derivation, which
doesn't have any simple--
any physical, say,
meaning, was actually used
in gravitational field to drive
the molecule as a disturbance
and derive the heat
flux correlation.
But say, what we need is--
so the book when I
present this, in fact,
I'm still not very confident
about that section.
So what we have, for
thermal disturbance,
and the distribution
function is exponential, say,
we can write exponential, the
Hamiltonian H, the energy,
a small volume, and
the kBt plus delta t.
Let's suppose, so
what I'm looking at
is the temperature
fluctuation inside the system.
Because of the
temperature fluctuation,
the local energy
has a fluctuation.
And I want to write,
what's the H prime?
The case, I want to
write which H prime.
And with this distribution,
and I can write from here,
I can write a H prime equals--
if I linearize
it, is a H itself,
which is the energy
Hamiltonian, which
is a function of position
and velocity, for example,
is a t, delta t, which could
be a function of r, and t and d
integration over the volume.
So this is my H prime.
And then, you have to
plug in this H prime
and go back to the derivation
and find that what's the f1.
And in the process, I have to
use the energy conservation.
And then I say, then you have to
integrate that over the volume
when you considering.
And what's the
boundary condition.
You check, and I
looked into many books.
I was never satisfied.
And I put-- what I finally
say, I have to complete this.
So you can check my book.
And so, if you do
this, what you have
is that you will derive a
thermal conductivity tensor.
And this is because
I have now a delta
t in the system,
temperature fluctuation.
And from temperature--
this delta t,
I can eventually derive
a thermal conductivity
tensor that is a V kBt
square 0 to infinite.
And the heat flux
expression either tau,
and the auto-correlation
of heat flux
between 0 and tau exponential
minus i omega tau d tau.
So this is the
Green-Kubo expression
for thermal conductivity.
And thermal conductivity
itself, again, could
be a function of frequency.
Because normally,
when we do heat,
we don't do very high
temperature-- high frequency.
So this is, in fact, this
is related to the Cattaneo
equation.
But Cattaneo equation
is never correct.
I've made the comment before.
Or it's very hard to be correct.
Because when you have a very
fast temperature disturbance,
you typically have a spatial
temperature gradient.
And if that gradient
is a longer--
shorter than mean-free path, you
can just use Cattaneo equation.
So what you should
do is actually write
both the frequency
and space dependent.
So time and space dependent
thermal conductivity.
And that gives you long node
core thermal conductivity,
which will be not only
a function of frequency
but also be a
function of V vector.
Nobody has done that.
I'm just telling--
I think that should be the case.
And in fact, I say, you see the
derivation I had before the f,
I said the system
is a uniform form--
force.
And here, that
disturbance temperature
could be spatially dependent.
If that's spatial
dependence, you
can write actually a
corresponding space dependence
wave vector and frequency
dependent expression--
thermal conductivity.
So now you have Green-Kubo.
And the beauty--
you should see, here
the beauty is it's an
equilibrium simulation.
You simulate a system box there.
Even though we
say, the derivation
process I have external force.
But at the end, all
those transfer property
is, I don't have a disturbance
anymore, or say, external force
anymore.
I just can simulate
the equilibrium system
and do my
auto-correlation function
and calculate
transfer properties,
viscosity, all those.
But you have to
have the expression
for what's the microscopic JQ.
In the case of current,
I have expression here.
So deriving this
microscopic expression
for the quantity that are of
your interest is the next step.
So what are those
microscopic quantities?
So for example, kinetic
energy, I want to calculate.
That's very easy.
Say, i equals 1 to n and
the p i squared to m.
And you can write the kinetic
potential, Hamiltonian, add up
kinetic and potential.
So simple one's easy.
And for heat flux--
and they are also--
heat and mass flux, in
fact, it's very easy.
The mass flux is
just the quantity--
is m Vi of-- or say, mi, Vi.
And i equals 1 to n.
And now, if you
do your heat flux,
and heat flux is
i equals 1 to n.
And Vi, H i is the enthalpy
of per molecule or atom
you're dealing with plus 1/2
of the interaction i equals j
equals 1, j does not equal to i.
And riJ, that's the distance
between the two atoms.
And the fiJ dot Vi.
So this one is--
this expression is
actually derived from the--
really, you write the energy
conservation for each atom.
And in the process, you
can derive the expression--
microscopic expression
for the thermal--
the heat flux.
And so, there are many
different microscopic expression
for different quantities.
The final comment
I want to make is,
when you simulate-- so here, in
the derivation, linear response
theory, I am doing
actually a canonic system,
constant temperature.
Now, when you do a molecular
dynamic simulation,
you typically fix
the number of atoms.
You try and maintain
the energies constant.
And then, when you
have a constant energy,
constant volume, constant number
of molecules, what do you have?
You have a
microcanonical example.
So how you can do a
microcanonical simulation,
and yet to represent
that I'm simulating
a system of constant
temperature or I'm simulating
a system of constant pressure.
And this is a--
people have spent a
lot of time trying
to deal with that question.
And here is the--
so how you stack--
thermostat the ensemble--
thermostatted ensembles.
So to do this, you actually also
have to get used to the fact
that normally you
do F equals ma.
That's the equation of motion.
But there are many different
ways to write the F equals ma.
And there are
[INAUDIBLE] equation
of motion, Hamiltonian
equation of motion.
They are all equivalent.
Not [INAUDIBLE],,
Lagrangian equation
of motion and Hamiltonian.
So for example, when you do a
Lagrangian equation of motion.
And what you use is r, r dot.
You use this the velocity and
space, say, as your variable.
And you construct the
Lagrangian of the system, which
is the function
of time, function
of r, function of velocity.
And Lagrangian of
the system is r dot
minus the potential energy.
So it's kinetic energy
minus potential energy.
Maybe you learn
this in dynamics.
And so, the Hamiltonian
principle-- so what's
the Lagrangian
equation of motion?
Is there is this
Hamiltonian principle,
say when your system
go from point one
to point two, the Lagrangian--
so the integral
here, integral-- this
is actually integral from
1 to 2 of the Lagrangian,
and tr, r dot.
And they integrate over time.
And this should be extreme.
It's a maximum or minimum.
And in fact, I don't
know whether it
should be maximum or minimum.
But see, it's a derivative of 0.
Derivative 0, from
there, you do variation.
You actually get the equation
of motion for the Lagrangian.
So you do your--
here you do the
equation of motion.
Then you will get,
this is the extrema.
You'll get a dL, dr.
Here, I have--
I'm writing in each
component the velocity.
And dL dr itself equals 0.
So this is the actually F
equal ma under the Lagrangian.
The Lagrangian is useful.
But it has one defect.
It's not symmetric.
It lacks symmetry.
And so, if you-- rather
than use r and r dot,
if you use r and p, this will
come back to the face space.
If you use the position and
momentum, and you actually
can do a transformation into the
Hamiltonian equation of motion.
So you can write,
rather than using
r, if you do your new
variable p momentum,
if you define equals the
Lagrangian derivative, that's
a momentum.
And you can go write a
Cartesian coordinate,
and you'll find this all
come back to F equal ma.
Everything makes sense.
And then you can construct
your Hamiltonian trp.
So now, my variable in
Lagrangian is r and r dot.
In Hamiltonian is r and p.
So this is sigma
dL dri, ri minus L.
And you can say, in
this simple, say,
case for kinetic plus
potential is essentially
if you're using Cartesian
coordinate, and you will say,
kinetic energy plus
potential energy.
This is what we typically
think about the Hamiltonian.
And once you have
the Hamiltonian,
you write the equation of
motion for a Hamiltonian is ri.
And r-- so the momentum
derivative and space derivative
is dH dpi.
So this one, you
can say compared
to Lagrangian
equation of motion,
this is a Hamiltonian
equation of motion--
the momentum and
space derivative.
And they are symmetric.
So that's the Hamiltonian
is often used.
Why I'm saying this?
Why I don't say I'm going into--
rather than F equal ma,
Lagrangian and Hamiltonian?
That's because, well, sometimes,
for example, if you write--
if you do a simulation of
molecules, the molecule--
you have a diatomic molecule.
It has, of course, each
model has two atoms.
If you say, I'm going to
simulate just r position
and velocity, I have to split.
I have to split this
molecule into two atoms.
But say, I can use theta,
say, the angle, rotation,
and the relative vibration.
So in that case, I have a
different variable, different
momentum, different coordinate.
So the beauty of the
Hamiltonian is that you
can write that much easier.
Now, what's the relation to
this, my original question?
I want to--
I do a simulation.
That's a microcanonical example.
And how I can simulate
a canonic using a--
say, to actually do
a canonical system
with a constant temperature?
And the trick here
is, this was creating
artificial Hamiltonian.
So for example, Nose
introduced a Hamiltonian.
And the Hamiltonian,
he wrote this is a--
he wrote r, not only r, but
also additional variable,
and the p prime
momentum, and the pS.
And in his Hamiltonian,
the time is a t prime.
And then, they say, it's
not even the real time.
The time is, say, related to--
so is says, dt equals
Sdt So you have
this additional S is your
equivalent of 1 of the r.
And then you have a
p, additional momentum
that was introduced.
And he said, this one equals
sigma i to n pi prime,
pi prime and 2m S squared
plus potential energy
is still the real space.
But he has an additional-- add
another term, this momentum.
So is this a 2mn.
So and plus, here is nf plus 1
and kBt log S. He cook this up.
And the reason he cooked this
up is, you write a Hamiltonian.
You can write the
equation of motion.
And he say, if I
simulate this system,
even though I simulate that
is a microcanonic example,
at the end I get a
canonical example
result for the original system.
So he actually proved it.
So the way you prove it, in
a microcanonical example,
you remember the entropy
is the k log omega.
Omega is a number of states.
So the number of states is
really just a dr dp prime.
And now I have extra dS dpS.
And then, this is a
counting number of states.
So is when the
energy of the system
is equal to the Hamiltonian,
that delta I have one state.
So this integration is just
a summation what it says.
So starting from here,
using this Hamiltonian,
you integrate the S and p prime.
pS, those are the two
extra he introduced.
He actually show that
after your integration,
what you have here is
a, say, nf plus 1--
this is the last equation
I'm going to write--
2 pi mn kBt 1/2
exponential E kBt.
I thought this was beautiful.
The people actually conjured
those ways of doing things.
That's why I want
to write to you.
And this is the Hrp and kBt.
So you see, the trick
is, he actually can--
going from this delta, he was
able to integrate that dS, dp.
And because he add
this log here--
in the equation of
motion, he add this log.
He got the exponent.
And then convert back into here
is your Boltzmann statistics.
And you can also prove if you
do a quantity of A, and then R,
say, that's the time average is
the same as ensemble average.
Except Nose had one problem.
So it was later Hoover said,
this was not necessary.
And going back to actually
go the real space,
and that actually
solve his problem.
So this is called the
[INAUDIBLE] thermostat.
And there are people develop,
say, for example, Anderson,
he developed a thermostat
where you can create
a constant pressure system.
So you have different--
so with that, you can write
different equations of motion.
So you add essentially
one equation
into a system of n particles,
you can solve the--
using that, you can deal with
the constant temperature,
constant pressure, different
constructions and examples.
OK.
12:30.
[LAUGHTER]
I thought I was going
to show some slides.
But remember, if you haven't
done your evaluation--
[LAUGHTER]
--say I at least I used time up.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.